we have the unsurprising
revelation
which i've mentioned a half a dozen
times in the last year and a half of the
pandemic
that coveted conspiracies are linked to
and pushing people towards
anti-semitism
um
this shouldn't really surprise too many
people if you've been watching this show
and we're going to talk about this new
report which is very interesting
um technology review has a summary
of the report by charlotte g which says
coveted conspiracy theories are driving
people to anti-semitism online old and
overtly anti-semitic fantasies are
gaining new utterance adherence
depending on your preference and
far-right activists have been working to
convert anti-lockdown beliefs into
anti-semitism too so it's happening both
ways
um a warning conspiracy theories about
covid are helping disseminate
anti-semitic beliefs to a wider audience
warns a new report by the anti-racist
advocacy group hope not hate
the report says not only has the
pandemic revived interest in the new
world order conspiracy theory of a
secret jewish-run elite that claims to
that aims to run the world but far-right
activists have also worked to convert
people's anti-lockdown and anti-vaccine
beliefs into active anti-semitism worst
offenders the authors easily managed to
find anti-semitism on all nine platforms
they investigated including tick tock
instagram twitter and youtube some of it
uses coded language to avoid detection
and moderation algorithms much of it is
overt and discoverable unsurprisingly
the authors found a close link between
the amount of anti-semitism on a
platform and how lightly or loosely it
is moderated the lack of the moderation
the bigger the problem of anti-semitism
we've talked before
about how
shadow government new world order
conspiracy theories have a lot of
different flavors many of which are
anti-semitic um we've talked about that
for a long time so that's one kind of
piece of this but the report which is
really very much worth looking at has an
entire section we're going to link to it
in the description to the youtube clip
for the story called conspiracy
ideologies covet 19 and anti-semitism
and i would you know go through it it
has a bunch of different uh ways in
which all of this stuff links to
anti-semitism one aspect of this is a
lot of new world order one world
government shadow government covet
conspiracies are interlinked with
widespread and long-standing
anti-semitic conspiracies where the
people doing the shadow government are
the jews
um could be
mixed in with
the build the bergs or um the trilateral
commission or it's the rothschilds or
you know there's different kind of
flavors of it but new world order shadow
government very much linked to
anti-semitism number two
um sometimes it's just the individuals
they blame are jewish individuals soros
is one classic example uh the other
aspect of this that we've seen is the
trivialization of the holocaust in covid
conspiracies the wearing of the yellow
stars
um or of the
uh
syringe swastikas that we've seen
floating around that's been happening a
lot and that's mentioned here so the
article the report rather
talks about anti-semitism as a
conspiracy tradition just like
most of these conspiratorial uh enclaves
have anti-semitic jew hatred there
it specifically talks about these
various trivializations of the holocaust
it talks about the role of the internet
specifically and that's a section that's
very much worth looking at
um it talks about the spread of
anti-semitic conspiracy ideologies
during the pandemic in europe it talks
about 5g 5g you know again we you have
to understand how all of these tropes go
together but they have the jewish
control of business thing and 5g
is a business thing and so you have that
blending together quite quite easily
it goes into specific examples in
different countries and the list of
countries is so long as you can see here
that i'm not going to read it all to you
and the other aspect of this is
far-right recruitment from the
conspiracy scene so this is just even
folks who fall for one conspiracy theory
or another related to kovid and then end
up in these facebook groups or different
circles even if they are not
previously anti-semitic uh or even link
the covet stuff to anti-semitism
the anti-semitic right-wingers white
nationalists etc know that these are
fertile recruiting grounds for pulling
people into the next step and if they
already have started to believe there's
a some kind of one-world conspiracy or
involving soros and uh bankers and bill
gates you know whatever i know bill
gates isn't jewish but the point is if
you're already in that universe
to say well you know have you noticed
that a lot of the people that are part
of this thing
happen to be jewish and here's a whole
bunch of other things that jews are
responsible for and then also i mean i
don't i think it's worth mentioning um
the idea of jews as caring disease
spreading disease which is a very very
old idea so
many of us
intuitively suspected that there were um
there was mixed in right
anti-semitism into a lot of this stuff
the signals were all there sometimes
it's explicit sometimes it's implicit um
and here it's sort of like in all of the
above type of scenario so check out the
report from hope not hate i don't think
you'll find anything particularly
shocking if you've been following
anti-semitism for any period of time but
the detail with which they break it down
and show you how you know in albania
here's how it's manifesting versus in
the netherlands and spain it's taking
this other um uh it has this other
flavor
very well done and very interesting so
check that out let me know your thoughts
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
we're gonna take a quick break and we've
got a tremendous program for you today
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com pacman i've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them you can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36 credit cards a month
and a 25 a month plan tailored more for
small businesses where you can create 60
card numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com slash
pacman